Trading felt impossible for me in the
beginning because every time I thought I
had figured out what the market was
doing, it would switch on me. It would
be trending and I'd enter into a trend
trade and boom, the trend would switch
on me. It would go sideways, turn into
chop, and I'd get stopped out losing
money. Or it would look like the
cleanest breakout ever. I'd go long
thinking it was about to explode and I
was going to make a ton of money. and
instead it would fake out, trap me,
everyone else, and reverse the other
way. And for a long time, I thought that
just meant I was unlucky. But the truth
is, it's not bad luck. That's what
happens when you're trading the market
without understanding what state it is
in. And more importantly, when the state
is about to change, because the market
doesn't just move randomly. It rotates
through the same five states over and
over again. And if you can't identify
which state you're in, you'll constantly
be using the wrong strategy at the wrong
time. Or you won't even know when it's
going to change into another state. So,
in this video, I'm going to break down
the five market states I look for every
single day. And I'm not just going to
tell you how to identify them after the
fact. You already know what's going on.
I'm going to show you the signals that
tell you when one state is ending and
another one is starting. Because once
you learn to spot that transition in
real time, you're going to stop getting
trapped and entering trades at the worst
possible moment and you can start
predicting and catching the exact move
that most traders are completely
missing. So, first off, let's talk about
the most basic one, a trend. A trend is
when the market is moving in one
direction. Quite often it's signaled by
making higher highs and higher lows for
an uptrend and it's making lower lows
and lower highs for a downtrend. Well,
to show you in an uptrend often a
healthy one has big moves up and shorter
pullbacks. This is the healthy way a
market moves up where it still has time
to make pullbacks before it continues
higher. Quite often to trade these what
you can do is you can buy it when it
comes to what you can eventually draw is
a trend line or quite often a healthy
trend will come to a previous swing high
bottom there and continue higher. It'll
make this stairstepping
pattern as it moves higher. And so these
are multiple ways to trade it is either
buying at the previous when it bottoms
at the previous swing high or if you can
identify a trend line, buy it when it
hits the trend line. Sometimes in the
best case scenario, this can line up at
the same time. Here's a great example
right here. We have a pretty clean
downtrend and then you have it making
pullbacks into that downtrend. Now,
let's talk about how you know when a
trend is going to end and those signals
that you need to know of so you avoid
getting trapped in the trend ending.
Well, first off, one is super simple is
it breaks this downtrend that you can
draw. That is the number one easy way to
do it. You know, you just draw off a
couple swings here and it breaks it.
Well, you can pretty much guarantee that
it's going to change. Now, when a trend
changes, it doesn't mean that it's going
to immediately reverse to the upside. It
could go three different directions. It
could reverse to the upside. It could
start going sideways, or it could
continue down. It could either
accelerate the downtrend, or it could
just go in a smaller, more shallower
downtrend. It just signals to you that
it's changing. It doesn't signal to you
exactly what it's going to do. And
that's with all of these examples. There
are other signals that can help you
predict what the next trend state will
be. Now, with this one, a good indicator
that it was going to start to go choppy
and sideways was well, one, it was near
the market close. The market closed
right here. And so, going into the
market close, you can assume it's
probably going to start chopping. And
also before it hit this downtrend, it
just chopped into the trend line.
Instead of having a normal move like it
was having before these two moves, it
had a move, a pullback that was healthy,
and then it bounced and continued lower.
And then it had a pullback that was
healthy. There was a couple choppy
candles in here, but here it had a move
down and then it just sat there. It
didn't have a pullback. And for me, once
something starts to just sit there for 5
to 20 candlesticks, that's a really good
signal. It's going to start just
chopping. You want to be aware of and
looking at the moves of the market. What
do the moves down look like? And what do
the pullbacks look like? You can see
these pullbacks start to get shallower
and shallower and then they almost
become nothing. And so in a way the
market is starting to get tighter and
tighter here, showing you that the
volatility is decreasing. This is how
you can really start to read into the
markets and understand what is
potentially happening and how the trend
is changing. And so instead of coming
here and betting and just blindly
knowing that, okay, well, there's this
downtrend here. It's here now. I want to
bet that it's going to continue lower.
You would see these other signals going
on and say, "Hey, I actually think I
should wait and sit out on this one
because it seems like it's likely that
it could just start to chop." And now,
zooming back here a little bit, this is
how a choppy trend can happen. So, here
is a recent trading day we had where the
market opened at 9:30 and it had a
couple of good moves here and overnight
it had massive volatility. And so you
think when the market opened that there
could continue massive volatility, but
instead it starts to chop. And so how do
you read that and predict that as it's
starting and developing and showing you
candlesticks over time? Well, one choppy
markets are identified for me with
overlapping candlesticks. You start to
see this here is much more of a trend.
You can see, you know, there's some
candlesticks that are choppy and
overlapping, but generally it's moving
in a direction and it's having
pullbacks. Versus here, it has a move
down, but then it gives that whole move
back up. Essentially, from the market
open to this point, it didn't move
anywhere. And then you have that happen
again where it moves all the way down,
hits this area, and moves all the way
back up. And so even on a smaller time
frame, you can say, well, it's volatile
back and forth and there's movement, but
over the course of 30 to 60 minutes, the
price hasn't actually gone anywhere. And
so this is signaling that it's being
choppy. And so even if you think that
there's large movement potential, you
have to understand and realize and
notice this and say, well, it's being
choppy. And so it's likely that it's the
movement here. you can see is it was
hitting this support zone down here
basically and these highs were getting
lower and lower. It's so it's going into
this wedge pattern and it's likely to
just start to sit there and be choppy.
And so that is a state where I always
avoid trading because it's super hard to
try and predict when the market is going
to come out of chop. Just like the same
thing of trying to predict when an
uptrend is going to end, it's really
hard to predict when chop is going to
change. Now, when it starts to get into
a state like this where it is literally
just not moving anywhere and it's like
trying to watch paint dry is what my
go-to rule always is, is wait. Just wait
it out. Don't do anything. Don't be
trying to predict when it's going to
break out because again, you could be
entering in here. You could be entering
in on this big candlestick thinking that
that's a signal that it's going to
continue lower and instead it just
reverses that and reverses that and
reverses that and sits there, right? And
you just don't know how long that's
going to go. It could go forever and it
can just move up here, hit this high and
then, you know, go back into a choppy
state. And so what I always do, my rule
of thumb with waiting for chop to change
is just waiting for the volatility to
come back. wait for it to break out of
let's say this support zone it had.
broke out here and reversed back in and
had started to show some volatility and
even then it kind of started it still
continued to sit there when that
volatility broke. And so sometimes this
is a day in the market basically this is
the first few hours the day eventually
after most of the day of chopping here
it went into that downtrend but some
choppy days it's better to just realize
it's choppy in the first hour and just
move on with your day. It's not worth
sitting there trying to predict
something because it's like trying to
make a shape out of clouds. You're going
to make something up that actually isn't
there. And when you're doing that with
trading, you're going to lose money.
Okay, let's go to the next state of a
reversal state. How do you tell when a
trend is actually going to reverse
versus turning into chop or just
continuing the uptrend? This is a huge
factor when it comes to trading and
trying to reversal trade because
predicting when a trend is going to
reverse versus continue is massive. And
so the biggest thing is it coming up to
a previous support or resistance zone.
So if you look at the market opened up
here actually there was news this is a
news spike and then it opened up and
tapped that news spike and kind of
kissed it goodbye before selling off.
Well, I would take a tool and say, "Hey,
well, this is a nice resistance zone
because the market's already fallen off
of there twice." And so, as the market,
you know, plays out kind of, it starts
to trend up here and it reverses from
the lows and trends up here, I would
call this an unhealthy trend or a very
fast tight trend. And we can use our
kind of trend indicators that we talked
about of it it kind of having this trend
line that's very tight. And then as soon
as it breaks that also looking at the
swings, right? The structure of this
market. If you look at here, it makes a
high here, makes a new swing low, it
makes a another attempt to continue
higher here and that fails. And so this
puts in a lower high. This low right
here is lower than this one. And so
that's showing you weakness because if
the market was strong, this would pull
back and continue higher in an uptrend.
Even if it's broken this trend, it would
continue if it was strong enough in a
new type of trend. It might start to
make something like this where you can
draw a trend line. But instead, it hits
here, bottoms, and then breaks this
making a new low. And that to me signals
weakness in the market. And so coupling
that with being at a area where the
market's already reversed twice is a
good signal that it's going to reverse
versus going sideways or continuing an
uptrend. And also because this trend
moved up so quickly, it didn't have
healthier pullbacks like this. It wasn't
a broad trend. It was a very tight
trend. it's more likely to have kind of
a bigger pullback. And so when this can
just turn into chop and either continue
higher or eventually reverse is if the
trend is strong enough that it hits this
area and starts to chop. Now a lot of
the times that will be signaled by more
of a broader healthier trend that has
pullbacks. If it has a tighter move like
this a lot of the times it will have a
pullback. Now, you can also have trends
that are so strong that even when they
hit this kind of area, they're not
really going to have a pullback and
they're going to continue higher. It
just takes a second to break through
this resistance zone. And how I identify
those is if the trend has happened for a
long time and it's a new day where the
market already hasn't shown that it's
reversing a lot. This day opened, went
up once, reversed, went up again, and
then so because of that, it's already
kind of been showing you that there's
volatility good for trading, but it's
more likely to continue with that
volatility of back and forth movement
versus if I zoom out, I'm trying to find
an example here where this market, this
is the previous day, the market opens up
here, makes a massive move up. That's
pretty unhealthy. But over time, you can
see it just continues higher and the
trend is just super consistent and
strong. And so even if you hit a
resistance level up here, I would start
to think, well, this trend is just
strong enough that it's it's had time to
pull back. And if it was going to pull
back and give this move that it had up,
well, it probably would have done it
here. But because it had that time to
consolidate and then it continued to
move higher, it's more likely that it's
going to continue higher and you should
stay away. So now let's go into a
breakout state. What makes the market
likely to break out as it hits a
resistance zone that it's already
reversed off of multiple times? How do
you tell that it's going to break out
versus hit this level and actually fail
like that example we were just looking
at? Now, one though is what does the
trend look like into that area? Is it a
healthy methodical trend that is showing
a lot of strength and it's been
continuing for a while and it's on a day
that's not choppy? That makes it more
likely to just continue higher. Now, as
well, I wouldn't bet against the trend
until that trend line is broken. So, if
the trend line is holding and it's
continuously just making new highs into
that resistance zone, it's likely to
break out versus reverse at this zone.
Another way to identify if something is
breaking out and it's going to continue
in that direction versus failing is we
have this example of this day here. The
market opens here at 9:30 and it's
choppy. Kind of like I was talking about
earlier. You would not want to bet or
look at the market to trade when it's
doing this. But the market attempts to
break out one direction here and then
reverses and breaks out the other side
of the overnight high and then it pulls
back as well. But you can see it pulls
back to essentially this upper range
that the market had. And because it's
already broken out one side, a lot of
the times I've noticed that if a market
is in, let's say, a chop range and it
breaks out one side and fails and then
it reverses and breaks out the other
side, it's likely that that side is
going to continue to the upside because
now it has strength behind it of faking
out the other direction, which we'll
talk about in a second. And so this then
continues higher. And you can start to
see here it broke out here and then made
a shallow pullback and then continued
higher as the day went on. Now, this was
the major move of the day, but it still
kind of had an uptrend into the end of
the day from there. Now, the final state
is called a failed breakout. It's
probably my favorite pattern, and I
think it's the one that's most
profitable as well. And here's a great
example of it. And so, what happens is,
you know, the market's in this choppy
state. we were talking about earlier.
And so you can pretty much at that point
say, okay, well, there's a pretty solid
support zone right here. And so what
happens is the market goes here and you
know it starts to increase in volatility
and it makes a big push with all these
big red candlesticks and breaks this
zone. And so a lot of times what
breakout traders say is, well, they
think, oh well, it's broken out of this
area. I'm going to wait for a quick
pullback here with this green candle and
then bet that it's going to continue
lower because I think we're breaking out
of this chop range and we're going to
start a downtrend. But you can more
easily predict that a failed breakout is
going to happen versus a breakout
because again look at the trend that
made the breakout happen. It is coming
from a choppy volatile market. So, this
trend isn't healthy and it doesn't have
pullbacks and so it's likely that it's
going to fail because of that because
it's doesn't have that much strength
behind it. And so, once it starts to
consolidate here, that tells you that
this momentum that came out of nowhere
is drying up and then it starts to make
a bottom here. And this candlestick
right here, if you kind of look at it,
well, that candlestick basically opened
up here, shot lower, and reversed. And
so what's happening here is it's
basically trending down. It makes a
bottom. It moves up and it makes one
more bottom. And that's showing you
essentially a double bottom. The market
is attempting to break this low again,
and it fails. And that failure is
showing you that it's not strong enough
to make a lower price. That's what that
is showing you. And because of that,
that is showing strength to the other
side. And it makes it likely that this
will reverse higher. And because this is
an overextended unhealthy move, it's
likely to rip this whole move back
before it slows down. And so it comes
back basically to where that move
started. And then from there, it goes
back into its choppy state. And so
trading bill breakouts like this is
extremely powerful for finding traps and
also catching big moves. Now, if you
want to learn how I've used these states
and turn them into a strategy with a
five-step simple entry checklist that
I've taught thousands of traders to
become consistently profitable using.
Check out this video right here. And as
well, I've got a free candlestick
patterns guide in the link in the
description below that'll go even more
in depth into price action movements and
states.